you cover Cults a lot too like yeah
that's my favorite if you're starting a
cult are you like I'm going to start a
cult or does it does it start with I'm
kind of this bully or I kind of want to
be popular and then it gets out of hand
and you're like I think I have a cult on
my hands it well they tend to like pop
out of religions because they're usually
losers yes oh yes almost always uh like
extreme Los like losers you're like this
is the guy you guys
are you to get to heaven this so they
have a chip on their shoulder and they
have a different kind of incentive
because they probably couldn't make it a
straight job yeah I it's funny now I
want to look the heights up of these
people I'm telling you we all want
answers you know and it's like no matter
how well life is going we all face death
we all face you know confusion you know
you and if you're lucky like the maso's
hierarchy of needs you get to that
self-actualization point and that's when
a lot of people get depressed where like
they've paid for everything they've set
themselves up everything is good but you
still have to face the inevitability of
your own death and the death of
everybody you love and that is
incredibly painful and traumatic to
really dwell in and think about I can
someone just give me a lie to believe
yep just give me something to believe
just make me feel good that this is a
transitional period that death is is not
real and I'm going to go somewhere where
the people I love are going to be there
like the appeal could not be fucking
stronger I personally believe uh I'm
spiritual well I believe that there is
some kind of creative power Powers
energy something I just don't think that
I don't trust some other person telling
me what that is definitively you know
it's like well you know you just trust
this oh really this book written 200000
Years Ago by idiots no thank you like uh
I I get there there's good lessons in
that book there's important parts where
I come from it's like it's like the
church with the book means free
babysitting on Sundays right well and
there's that too the the community stuff
where it's like if you're struggling
let's say you're like a single mom and
and there's not much money and all these
things and then there's this group
people are and where else are you going
to take your kids on Sundays you know
like where else you going get a dose of
faith that says everything's going to be
better if you just believe in something
like we all have our own anesthesia
whether you're going down to the bar and
going to drink some whiskey whether
you're going to smoke some weed or
whether you're going to go to church you
know it's like and there are good
churches you know it's like it was hard
for me to say that for a while but there
are ones that are like you know what
we're interpreting this the best we can
do I think I all this stuff is literally
true no but I think that there is some
God that's looking out for us it's like
they get kind of like loose with it I'm
like MH okay cool but it's also I think
part of the the um purpose of religion
if you're going to besides to make money
in the beginning you know was also to
control people the same way Santa was
invented to because someone was like
someone's watching you and if you're
naughty you're not getting toys and then
kids are like oh God and that was like
surveillance for the year it's a way to
control kids it's like the Grims fairy
tales and all the folklore the Boogeyman
and all these different cultures yeah it
was just a way to get kids to go bed yes
exactly you leave the and please don't
leave the house cuz there are wolves and
and people will eat kids or whatever cuz
they were Savages it's been so long ago
yeah and I think like and if it's if
you're if there are people out there not
cheating on their wives or not stealing
cuz they think God is watching like is
that so bad what's your favorite cult
I'm in between Wild Wild Country once
you're putting a beaver in a blender I'm
all in I'm all in but like they had to
took over a town in Oregon how did they
get so much money that guy was the guy
that that Osho cult right he was driving
Bentley he oh he had so many Bentley so
when you're steady progression in the
cult yeah you're not like doing the math
on this I mean they had their own
airport with a plane oh yeah oh yeah
they were they were trying to build I
think they were like buying in of like
well that cult and the one in analou
organ a lot of them there was a lot of
orgies and stuff going on and and it was
like that kind of I don't know why I
think they put something in the water
too it wasn't lithium but I think
something the water um but I remember it
was like you know that whole kind of
like yoga new age I don't know where
that got attached to more affluent
people yeah but it does like there were
was a a time especially like 70s 80s
where it was like the cool new thing for
wealthy uh people a lot of like wealthy
women to go to India go on these yoga
retreats and things and then there were
people like that Guru I can't remember
his name that would exploit that so I
think early on that guy figured out that
Bajan
uh bwan bwan Raj Nishi or something yeah
oh why did I think it was Osho is that
the same person sometimes they would
have different names maybe he was one of
those yeah his name is bwan Shri rajnish
o oh okay o because I had lots of his
books when I first moved to LA and I was
like reading the secret and listening to
Abraham Hicks and I was reading oh my
God Abraham Hicks oh my God yeah yep yep
uh you got a The Law of Attraction and
all this they always take shit too far
you know the secret and here's what I'll
say look there's elements of it that are
good
elements did it work or not you tell me
I me I in I think also but when you go
like these vitamins work they changed my
life but also the kind of person that
went and bought the vitamins is probably
also working out also taking care of
themselves also eating well I don't
think anyone just like goes I'm going to
buy some vitamins and they just keep
eating McDonald's all day the kind of
person that goes and buys the secret is
probably already the person who's going
to work really hard anyway so it's hard
to delineate I had a friend pushed the
secret on me so hard and I finally like
started to read it and I got so angry I
L threw it in the trash and then just
with him cuz it was that what bothered
me was this when they take it a good
premise too far and it was like you know
you just got to be more positive you got
to to attract more positivity if you
don't have what you want it's just cuz
you're not POS yeah you're not being
positive and immediately my brain went
to like all these kids in like War torn
Africa who grew up you know like they're
literally they have Aid because they
have bad attitudes yeah you got a
attitude that's why you were born with
AIDS that's if you had a better attitude
then your your um neighbor wouldn't have
eaten your brother after gutting him
with the machete like whatever the hor
thing yes yes yes so I remember uh he
got so mad it was actually it might have
kind of tilted our friendship to no
longer being friends this one phone call
but I left him a voicemail I was like
hey dude I got to apologize I know I've
been giving you a lot of about the
secret but I finally like gave it a
chance and it's awesome man it's it's
it's everything you said it was going to
be you just have to manifest things it's
so cool but as I'm leaving you this
voice me I'm actually holding on to an
eagle and he's just taking me through
the air because that's what I manifested
you
your stupid book